helping put food on the table community
kitchens like this are starting up
around sri lanka as people struggle with
its worst economic crisis in more than
70 years food inflation has hit nearly
60 percent and many people are finding
it difficult to cope most of these
communities who are coming today or been
coming are surviving with two meals so
we are giving them the responsibility of
surviving for one meal and we are saying
right we will support you with one meal
but a good healthy meal few now get to
eat this well
it's very difficult we rarely get food
like this only my husband is working but
what he earns for a day is not enough to
feed the three of us now
tax cuts three years ago slashed
government revenue by more than two
billion dollars the tourism industry was
then damaged by the easter bombings and
the pandemic
now there is no money to import fuel
medicine cooking gas or food right now
actually our main focuses are on food
banks on community kitchens and again
long to medium term
community gardens and home gardens
because we can give rations but it's
very short term the government is
appealing for help
we urgently require
the assistance of our friends in the
international community to ensure that
our immediate needs in terms of the
importation of essential medicines
food supply
and fuel i mean
india and china have sent food and
medicine in recent days
the opposition says the government has
weakened the economy through populist
policies and mismanagement
a nationwide campaign dubbed gota go
home has been running for two months
calling on the president to resign
the government is seeking a loan package
from the international monetary fund or
imf
critics say it'll take too long even if
agreed and people need action now
tens of thousands of sri lankans are
going hungry amid the country's worst
economic crisis in decades community
kitchens like this can only feed a
fraction of them mineral fernandez al
jazeera colombo